a staged exit a signature fist pump a
president who wants you to see him as a
Phoenix rising from a virus he still
actually has you think you might be a
super spr
Mr still on steroids he took to the
[Applause]
skies the images fittingly
euphoric
his first act suitably defiant removing
his mask before telling the nation to
resist fear don't let it dominate you
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have the best medical
equipment we have the best medicines all
developed recently and you're going to
beat it I went I didn't feel so good and
two days ago I could have left two days
ago two days ago I felt great like
better than I have in a long time I said
just recently better than 20 years ago
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your
[Music]
lives and a White House preoccupied by
Hollywood not allegations of hypocrisy
producing their own musical tribute to
their all conquering Chief Now cast as
the Ultimate
Survivor we're going back we're going
back to work we're going to be out front
as your leader I had to do that I knew
there's danger to it but I had to do it
I stood out front I led nobody that's a
leader would not do what I did and I
know there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay and now I'm better and maybe
I'm immune I don't know he was hugely
helped by an Ever upbeat medical team we
all remain cautiously optimistic um and
on guard uh because we're in a bit of
unchartered territory when it comes to a
patient that received the therapies he
has so early in the course um so we're
looking to this weekend if we can get
through to Monday with him remaining the
same or improving better yet uh then we
will all take that final deep sigh
relief
but the President's White House has
become increasingly engulfed by coid 19
and he's not out of the woods yet
either Cordelia Lynch Sky News
Washington